Từ từ Ankeh Stammer, ngày 1, 2, đường bố sẽ không từ trước.
Dù đối mặt sự áp ngày càng lượng về việc tưởng bộ nhiệm Peter Maderson làm đại sự Ankeh Mi.
Vụ việc buông lên khi có mù liên hệ trong quà khư dễ ống mẹ đề sân và tội phạm tình dục quà cố,
Jeffree Stain bị công khá chờ lại sau rọt vô sơ mởi được phía Mỹ công bố.
Hãy lãnh đạo công đảng và School Land,
anas sau hoa kêu quà ông Stammer từ trước.
Châu rằng chân kái đàn làm giản đoạn hoạt động của chính phủ.
Cùng thời điểm 2 cho li cấp cao của ông Stammer cũng liên kếp rồi nhịp sợ trong trường đại bố Mỹ tạm giờ
đầu tiên là trình văn phòng phủ tụt tưởng kiểm cho li thân cận Mocken Masweenie
ông này từ trước và nhận trên nhận từ bần cho quy định bộ nhiệm mà đời sân
người thứ 2 là giảm đốc chuyển thông tim Allen.
Chứ sẽ gái ông Stammer phát biểu chứ căng nghỉ xí công đảng rằng
sẽ tiếp tục thực hiện nhập kỳ được cụ chào và không để đất nước rồi và bất ông.
Văn phòng thủ tưởng cụ cho biết ông có nhẹn kiểm năm và vẫn nhận được xương hộ của nhớ bộ chường các cao
về phần tu đại xương mà đời sân ông này hiện đang bị cạnh sát yếu tra liên quan tởi
mối quan hệ vị phám công vụ với Jeffrey F. Stain và chưa được ra bị glợt công khai.